suite un petit sondage que je vous ai
posté dans l'onglet communauté vous avez
été une grande majorité à vouloir une
vidéo sur le grand final de la saison 2
demande alors ya une vidéo un petit peu
plus de schille évidemment car qui dit
fin de saison dit forcément gros trois
théories qui arrive semaine prochaine
sachez en tout cas que cette vidéo
spoile sera évidemment bande à laurianne
saison 2 ainsi que des petites séries la
saga star wars en elle-même et des
petites séries comme genre rebelle
donc voilà vous êtes prévenus cette
vidéo va clairement me servir comme
introduction pour le 3 théorie car après
une fin de saison comme ça j'aime bien
pouvoir débattre avec vous via les
commentaires et tous afin d'avoir les
idées claires se mettre les idées en
place et sait être clair sur et sert à
quoi je profite également pour vous
rappeler que si vous souhaitez nous
rejoindre
n'hésitez pas on va parler de mandat
lauriane star wars ou tout autre sujet
hype comme marvel avec spider man 3 vous
êtes vraiment nombreux à regarder les
vidéos sans être abonné donc voilà je
vous invite clairement à le faire et
nous rejoindre il faut tout d'abord
qu'on parle de l'arrivée de luc et ouais
j'avoue je commence fort on avait parlé
du futur de star wars via une vidéo
dédiée et bon sang on a vraiment vu
juste puisque deux semaines après disney
nous annonce 10 nouvelles séries ainsi
qu'une onzième bien la fin de cette
saison deux mandats lauriane je sais que
beaucoup n'aiment pas entendre ça mais
star wars se marrent veliz en quelque
sorte
mais la saga en avait vraiment besoin
star wars avait besoin de s'extirper de
la trame principale pour proposer de
l'inédit et du coup d'autres séries qui
sont reliées entre elles
c'est clairement ipod je vous
l'annonçais je ne me suis jamais senti
aussi hype et par star wars que depuis
l'annnonce du retour de la saga avec
star wars 7 et concernant l'udc
j'avais une énorme crainte car
effectivement l'intriguent de bébés yoda
ou
gros goût était de retrouver le peuple
jedi entre guillemets mais je pensais
même que ça allait être le but final de
la série et non juste de cette saison
est le problème que j'avais avec luc et
qu'il est justement le symbole de cette
trame principale dont on s'extirpe
jamais donc voilà c'est à dire que
mandanda l'organe allait tomber dans le
piège pour moi d'avoir une finalité qui
se résument en finale à la trame
principale et donc ne pas rester
indépendant comme on nous proposait
depuis le début mais au final c'est très
bien réfléchi c'est très bien amené et
du coup l'arc gros goût avec l'udc se
termine sur cette saison 2 mais
franchement c'est là que mandaloriennes
va devenir clairement intéressant et
hype
même si on aime gros goût et l intrigue
qu'il apportait d'inge arin est libéré
de sa mission et va nous proposer une
toute nouvelle histoire puisque la
finalité de gros goût était de retrouver
luc et donc la trame principale
l'udc qui s'en va avec gros go annonce
clairement qu'il est temps pour jean
jouines de balancer son histoire à lui
dans la saison 3 et la saison 4
maintenant concernant son histoire
justement dean va suivre beau catane
comme il en avait parlé avant la
bataille avec le mof et là quelque chose
m'intrigue beaucoup voir me coince c'est
que mundo a battu guy dionne et a
récupéré le sabre noir une tradition
importante pour les mandaloriens qui
fait que hbo catane ne peut pas être la
digne détentrice du sabre qui pourrait
réunir tous les mandaloriens sauf que je
suis obligé de vous parler de rebelles
une série d'animations qui donne
beaucoup d'inspiration et de portes
ouvertes
amanda lauriane et bien sabine wren
donne le sabre noir a beau catane qui
est désignée comme la plus légitime à
gouverner et elle ne le refuse pas donc
je bloque sur le fait qu'elle leur
fuselage et là je pense qu'il faudra
attendre la véritable histoire du
pourquoi du comment move qui donne à
récupérer le sabre face à boca thann
peut-être que les mandaloriens restant
savent qu'elle a échoué face à guy des
hommes et cela expliquerait pourquoi
elle tient absolument à le vaincre
d'elle-même
on parlait justement de sabine foraine
sabine est pour moi la plus grosse
intrigue est le plus gros point
d'interrogation demande à lorient nous
avons eu la présence d'ahsoka tano dans
un épisode
un épisode qui nous a montré qu à
saucats est toujours dans sa quête celle
de retrouver le grand amiral tron et qui
dit rhône dit également retrouver aux
rats le but originel de la quête puisque
ahsoka était sauvé par israël a une
dette envers lui et parce que sabine a
pour mission de retrouver et sera
bridgeurs et c'est là le hic ou est
sabine surtout que david filoni l'un des
producteurs de la série mandat lauriane
avec jon favreau est une figure très
importante de la série d'animation star
wars roberts et ce dernier profite
justement demande à laurianne pour
étendre les portes restées ouvertes dans
rebels
donc c'est qu'il ya forcément une raison
derrière tout ça derrière l'absence de
sabine je pense faire une grosse théorie
là-dessus pour le 3 théorie mais il est
peut-être possible qu'au final
ahsoka soit à la recherche de trône
tandis que bah justement
sabine est quant à elle à la recherche
des draps donc voilà le truc et que est
ce que tout ça sera développé dans
l'intrigué de la série à venir sur
ahsoka tano et non d'amanda lauriane il
est clair que s'il existe une série sur
ahsoka cela nous montrera son périple
suite à à rebels qui restent floues elle
est toujours à la recherche de tron cinq
ans après la fin de rebelles ce cinq ans
après la bataille de jack ou mais
aurons-nous des éléments de cette
intrigue danda lauriane difficile à
savoir mais vu que hbo catane connaît
très bien sabine et que son but est d'
aujourd'hui de restaurer mandalore
peut-être se tourneraient tel à
retrouver sabine puisqu'elle a marqué
l'histoire de son peuple
surtout que si beau catane sait où se
trouve à souk ahras okah est parti avec
sabine donc voilà et peut-être à
retrouver la maison wrens il en existe
encore puisqu'il ya eu la grande purge
je vous rappelle dont nous savons encore
peu de chose peut être il y at il des
informations que je n'ai pas par le
biais de comics des shows
le canon évidemment je pense que vous
serez me le dire en commentaire si nous
passons maintenant aux mauves qui
détonne il ya clairement des choses
intéressantes à souligner maintenant que
gros goût est partie aux côtés de luc la
question de la trame principale les jedi
la force et cetera
c'est un petit peu écartés on va dire et
surtout même si le mof bluffait contre
d'inge arin il le dit clairement il
préfère garder le sabre noir plutôt que
gros goût sabre noir dont il connaît
parfaitement la symbolique mof a fait
exprès de combattre d'inge arin car dans
les deux cas il serait gagnant même
s'ils perdaient le combat il savait que
hbo catane n'auraient pas accès au sabre
noir
il est très au fait des coutumes
mandaloriennes mais pourquoi en fait
c'est là une intrigue très importante je
trouve pour la suite
pourquoi tout cet intérêt pour la
défaite des mandats lauriane pourquoi
vouloir les purges et pourquoi mof
guider on s'intéresse autant aux
mandaloriens il y à un mystère derrière
tout ça et on ne sait pas si mauvais
guide et ron est un mof autoproclamés ou
non mais si il ne l'est pas cela
sous-entend qu'un possible palpatine la
nommer comme tel on ressent d'ailleurs
une énorme vague dark vador dans gi des
hommes dont il semble s'inspirer
si palpatine a nommé guy des hommes en
tant que mof
cela sous-entend qu'il ya quelque chose
chez les mandaloriens qui intéresse
palpatine
peut-être qu'il s'agit du sabre lui même
guide et on avait besoin de gros bout
pour des expériences de clonage et on
sait que palpatine notamment dans star
wars neuf étaient reliés au clonage est
la création de la vie d'être lié à la
force comme snow par exemple le sabre
aurait permis à palpatine de prendre le
dessus sur les mandaloriens et les
gouvernés entre guillemets mais surtout
il est possible que gros goût soit en
fait à l'origine de la création de ce
nom
grâce aux expériences qu'il a subies et
la récupération son sens peut être que
les résultats ont permis la création de
snacks et donc l'avènement du premier
ordre quelques années plus tard
il est possible qu'on en reparle dans la
vidéo 3 théorie parce que là c'est quand
même quelque chose d'énorme est très
important et pour en revenir à gros goût
quelque chose me 30 en tête d' assez
terrible mais l'udc doit protéger gros
goût et l'entraîné dans son académie
pour qu'il devienne un jedi
sauf que vous savez ce qu'il adviendra
de l'académie de luke cage lorraine
naîtra et se retournera contre l'udc et
les autres élèves par la suite
mais bon il est possible qu'il y ait une
petite pirouette scénaristique pour
sauver gros bout enfin voila on termine
rapidement sur l' annonce de la série
sur boba fett cela faisait un moment que
cette idée exister sur internet et du
coup elle est enfin là elle est enfin
réel effectivement boba n'est pas
vraiment un mental rien et c'est là où
je vous disais dans la vidéo sur
l'avenir de star wars que mandaloriennes
est un petit peu ce qu'était la première
trilogie autrefois mandaloriennes agit
comme une sorte de point 0 et balance
plein de nouvelles intrigues à gauche et
à droite qui deviendront de nouvelles
histoires et c'est donc à saucats
anneaux boba fett les rangers de la
république il est un petit peu à
l'origine de l'inédit dans cette
nouvelle ère star wars boba fett va donc
reprendre son influence sur tatouine et
a repris la place que possédait déjà bas
dans star wars 4 5 et 6 avec son acolyte
m'échappe il va devenir le grand patron
de tatouine bref je suis curieux d'avoir
vos retours et vos avis
c'est vraiment la vidéo pour débattre
autour de mandaloriennes et de cette fin
de saison
comptez sur moi pour vous proposer un
bo3 théorie ça sortira la semaine
prochaine normalement il n'y a pas de
raison j'espère que la vidéo vous aura
sincèrement plus n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner c'est très important de laisser
un petit pouce bleus à me donner votre
avis évidemment et puis bah écoutez
c'était arcoroc et que le lionheart soit
avec vous allez ciao tout
[Musique]